[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tanis
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
guillaume pitron pour son livre-enquête
l'enfer numérique aux éditions les liens
qui libèrent quel est l'impact sur la
planète de nos mails de nos laïcs de dos
elfi sur instagram et bien c'est bien
pire que la pollution générée par les
transports aériens vous allez comprendre
pourquoi je recevrai ensuite davidas
d'un code qui joue son nouveau one man
show ça va aller à la nouvelle scène et
la grande pianiste claire marie le guay
pour son album consacré à franz liszt
intitulé joie de l'âme est en cause mais
ans tout de suite par voulions pitron
voici une image que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque est une
image qui allait retirer de votre livre
en fait parce que c'est pour ça qu'elle
m'a inspiré ces images d'un photographe
chinois qui s'appelle luongo qui
s'appelait d'ailleurs parce qu'on ne
sait pas ce qu'il est devenu a disparu
en 2018 parce que il prend des photos de
la pollution en chine et toutes ces
photos sont complètement saisissante
elles sont extrêmement marquante à
l'image de cette photo là où je suis
très marquée par le regard de cet
ouvrier qui a l'air de travail
visiblement dans des hauts fourneaux on
imagine le charbon le voit barbouillé de
charbon ça raconte la façon dont
l'électricité produite en chine ça
raconte la pollution atmosphérique qui
est un des grands sujets de pollution en
chine et qui crée beaucoup de tensions
internes de la chine c'est une image
très très actuel mais malheur des
énergies vertes que cette image qui dit
beaucoup de choses de la chine et qui
dit aussi combien c'est difficile quand
on prend ces photos d'exercer ce métier
en chine puisque son auteur on ne sait
pas ce qu'il est devenu là pour écrire
l'enfer numérique vous avez suivi
pendant deux ans sur tous les continents
vous êtes allé en chine notamment la
route de nos emails de no light des
vidéos et des photos que nous postons
sur internet on croit que le numérique
n'a aucun impact matériel sur la planète
qu'il est à proprement parler immatériel
en fait il faut un la pollution digital
est considérable c'est bien pire que le
trafic aérien elle est considérable tout
ce qui est virtuel et matérielles pour
fabriquer des téléphones portables pour
fabriquer des centres de données c'est à
dire ces fermes de serveurs dans
lesquels sont stockés no light nos
photos de vacances pour fabriquer des
câbles sous marins forcément il faut de
la matière il faut du plastique il faut
des métaux il faut de l'électricité
puisque les centres de données ils
tournent 24 heures sur 24 il faut
qu'internet soit toujours disponible
parce que moi peut-être vous et moi je
suis très pressé sur internet je peux
pas attendre une seconde que ma ma page
web se télécharge donc pour ça il faut
qu'ils ce qu'on appelle une
disponibilité de service et donc ont
redoublé datacenter rien et qui servent
à rien mais ils sont là au cas où le
premier serait tombé en panne et tout ça
bien c'est une gigantesque consommation
d'électricité qui d'électricité dits la
photo qu'on a vu charbon gaz naturel
pétrole nucléaire énergies renouvelables
en tout cas ça un coup co2 un impact co2
et c'est ce que vous dites 4% des
émissions de co2 sont générés
aujourd'hui à peu près par le par le
numérique à peu près 4 % et c'est
quasiment deux fois plus que l'ensemble
du secteur civil aérien mondial le livre
est sous titré voyez le voyage d'un like
tout le monde ne sait pas ce qu'elle ait
mais on va en voir un derrière moi après
qu'on ait vu votre livre
c'est quoi un résumé mois le voyage de
ce petit de ce petit pouce mon
grand-père 93 ans hier me dit guillaume
qu'est ce qu'un live quand je lui ai
expliqué que ce corner sur un réseau
social comme facebook par exemple on
peut dire qu'on apprécie ce qui est
posté donc on peut mettre un coeur un
pouce façon de mettre d'accord
finalement ça raconte aussi notre c'est
un geste qui symbolise un peu nos
actions on digitalisées du quotidien que
l'on réalise nonchalamment et dans l'âme
et même tous ceux qui postent quelque
chose dit veulent qu'on les like ils
veulent qu'on les like donc sacs raconte
notre notre vie de plus en plus numérisé
à quel point ils sont peut-être devenu
accro à internet et ses like comme les
photos de vacances comme les swype
thirteen d'heure ou comme une vidéo de
chat et bien tout ça ça passe par des
réseaux donc si moi je décide de liker
l'un des contenus que vous postez sur un
réseau social si vous en avez un eh bien
je vais pas à liker de mon téléphone à
votre téléphone que vous sur lequel vous
allez recevoir le like sap affaires de m
cela et qui va transiter par une antenne
4g il va descendre sous terre il va
passer par des réseaux souterrains des
câbles qu'après des réseaux sous marins
est ce qu'en fait nous like passe sous
la mer beaucoup plus sous la mer
d'ailleurs que au dessus de nos têtes
dans les satellites via des satellites
il va être stockés dans des data center
plusieurs data center à la fois pour
cette justement cette idée de redondance
il a parfois des mets de kilomètres pour
arriver finalement pour faire les deux
mètres que je croyais qu'il avait fait
donc en réalité il ya un impact énorme
donc l'idée ça a été dans deux ans me
voyez le terrain de raconter étape par
étape qu'est ce qui se passe quand on
envoie un like et l homme masqué je me
suis dit mais alors le jour il y aura
des robots il ya déjà des robots vous
gagnez beaucoup plus de robots on
s'attend ce qui est beaucoup beaucoup de
robots beaucoup plus que ceux
d'aujourd'hui ça va être encore pire les
robots vont polluer encore plus que les
humains déjà les robes ou les fermes de
troll par exemple les fermes de troll
géré par les humains mais aussi des
fermes de troll automatisés bon déjà il
ya des robots qui crée une attention
factice sur internet facebook est
parfaitement au courant de ça facebook
dit d'ailleurs le groupe dit lui-même
faut pas regarder exactement faut pas se
fier aux nombres de vue exacte de
certaines de nos vidéos parce que on
sait que ce sont quelques fois des
fausses vue mais qui sont générés
automatiquement par des robots qui
déclenche des bus pour faire monter la
mayonnaise donc en fait ce que j'ai
constaté c'est que internet c'est pas
qu'il va faire du bien ça ne s'arrête
pas quand je me couche et ça ne se
reconnaissent pas quand je me lève en
réalité pendant que nous nous occupons à
nouveau à diverses activités et ben en
fait les robots prennent le relais à
telle intention à tel point qu'en fait
internet en train de devenir de plus en
plus une affaire de robots et de moins
en moins une affaire de demain
d'ailleurs
les données ont été jusque maintenant
des données bits ou si c'est à dire des
données qui peuvent être générées alors
soit entre personnes physiques c'est à
dire si tous y clio clio clients be to
see entre une personne physique et puis
une entreprise qui va avoir intérêt à
pompey s'est donnée jeudi pomper c'est
déjà très péjoratif mais voilà et puis
après il ya la donne et industriel c'est
à dire juste de la donne et qui est
produite par les banques pour les
banques avec des banques pareil pour l'
usine 4.0 demain l'usiné ultra connectés
et donc toutes ces données c'est
gigantesque
et ça tombe tout seul et donc en fait
née nettoyer mon email c'est sympa mais
en fait le problème ce n'est pas tant la
pollution - ims toute la pollution
générée automatiquement par semaine
imaginons pas tous les objets sont
connectés ce sera là absolument délirant
vous le dites cette pollution et est
d'abord due aux 34 milliards
actuellement il ya 34 milliard
d'ordinateurs de tablettes de
smartphones
que nous utilisons pour aller sur
internet c'est déjà c'est déjà ça un
rien que vous citez le cas des batteries
des batteries de de nos milliards de
téléphones dedans il ya de la graphite
par exemple absolument ici on fait le
total c'est plus de 50 matières
premières dans un smartphone voilà
cinquante parce qu'un téléphone portable
sert à beaucoup d'autres choses que
téléphoner est aussi un un appareil
photo il ya aussi un dictaphone il ya
aussi un outil de géolocalisation est en
fait pour faire des téléphones qui soit
à la fois surpuissant qui nous
permettent de faire des tas de choses à
la fois et puis également des téléphones
qui soit beau joli agréable à porter
léger il faut toujours plus de ces
matières premières est en fait ce que
j'ai découvert c'est qu'un téléphone
portable ne pèse pas 150 ou 200 g il
pèse 70 80 90 100 kg peut-être davantage
150 kilos parce que la matière qui a été
mobilisée durant tout le processus de
fabrication du téléphone pour arriver au
produit fini par cette matière là on
commence à calculer on commence à faire
un ratio entre la matière mobilisés et
puis le produit fini et on se rend
compte qu'en fait l'impact de nos vies
numériques est extrêmement important
beaucoup plus lourd mais d'un point de
vue des volumes littéralement des poids
que les jolis objets qu'on a sous la
main plus c'est petit plus en fait en un
mot il ya de la matière et plus et
virtuels plus paradoxalement fait ces
matériels et c'est bâtir près bien il
faut les extraire il faut extraire et
d'enchaîner en chine dans les mines de
grafite vous en parliez graphique qui
est un composant essentiel de nos
batteries de téléphones portables j'ai
joué au chat et à la souris avec les
autorités chinoises heureusement mon
destin est un peu meilleur que celui du
photographe on entend parler au début
c'est très compliqué d'être dans ces
zones là je raconte concrètement comment
ça se passe mais voilà il faut être au
milieu de ces zones-là de comprendre le
grand n'importe quoi pour extraire le
graphique de téléphone portable sur tout
l'est l'obsède quand on connaît
l'obsolescence c'est-à-dire la durée
moyenne de vie d'un ordinateur ou d'un
téléphone c'est quoi quatre ans à peu
près
moyenne de taux cumulés et et ensuite ce
sont des déchets électroniques on en
envoie des images là vous dites alors
vous donner un chiffre absolument c'est
nous produisons chaque année
l'équivalent de 5000 tour eiffel de
déchets électroniques comme ça 5000 tour
eiffel chaque année et on pourrait tout
à fait en produire au moins la moitié si
déjà nous avions la patience de ne pas
changer de téléphone tous les 18 mois ou
tous les deux ans en moyenne l'iphone 13
vient de sortir je peux vous garantir
qu'il y aura dans les rues de toutes les
capitales du monde des files entières de
gens avec un iphone 12 dans la main
qu'ils ont achetée il ya pas si
longtemps est prêt à acheter une
nouvelle fois une 13 parce que c'est ce
qu'on appelle de l'obsolescence culturel
mon produit anciens fonctionne très bien
mais je suis tellement tenté par le
nouveau que du coup je vais va enfin
mettre au rebut le précédent alors
espérons qu'ils soient revendus sur une
plateforme de revente en ligne ça existe
aujourd'hui mais en fait cette
observation se participe de plein
d'obsolescence le fait que la batterie
soit collée au téléphone quand la
batterie tombe en panne on change de
téléphone alors qu'on pourrait changer
la batterie ça c'est l'obsolescence et
aussi des objets de licences logicielles
vous avez un vieux téléphone avec un
nouveau logiciel dessus un nouvel os
comme on dit opérating système et au
téléphone en fait il est le hardware à
la matière elle-même fonctionne mais le
software dessus ne fonctionne pas et
comme notre compatibilité vous allez
changer le hardware parce qu'il faut
changer le sort d'autres exemples que
vous donner c'est quand les chinois tout
à coup ne veulent pas être vulnérable
vis-à-vis des américains dont décide de
remplacer tout le matériel informatique
américain qu'ils ont par du matériel
chinois mais s'est tout à coup une
génération entière à l'échelle d'un pays
comme la chine de matériel qui part à la
casse c'est ce qui s'est passé justement
en 2019 je crois en chine la chine tout
d'un coup énoncera le gouvernement est
long ce qu'il faut changer d'un seul
coup tout un tas d'ordinateurs
de ce qu'on appelle des terminaux
numériques des ordinateurs qui ont été
fabriquées aux états unis avec à
l'intérieur des logiciels américain donc
tout d'un coup on se craint de
l'espionnage or ces ordinateurs servent
pour l'administration chinoise et la
migration chinoise dit mesure de
souveraineté protection face à un risque
d'espionnage potentiel on lit qui tout
est dans ce que j'appelle une purge
électronique donc y avait des purges
politiques vous n'êtes pas conforme à
l'idéologie du parti ou la mauvaise
nationalité on vous purge et ben là
c'est la même chose est pas conforme à
une certaine idéologie du parti vous
avez pas la bonne nationalité on vous
purge et tout ça par potentiellement
revue alors ça c'est la pollution déjà
on l'a dit pour les moyens de ton qui
nous sont nécessaires pour accéder à
internet ensuite il ya la pollution qui
provient des données que nous produisons
alors celle-ci on croit qu'elle est
immatériel on se rend pas compte les
ordinateurs on voit bien quand on les
jette on se dit ah c'est pas très bien
mais en revanche quand on envoie un like
on se rend pas compte que en fait les
câbles tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
dire et tribus les informations à les
stocker c'est de la pollution oui alors
cette donnée comme on l'a rapidement
évoqué d'abord elle va être
donc on a transité via les câbles le
câble ne génère pas beaucoup de
pollution objectivement un tuyau qui
fait la taille d'un tuyau d'arrosage
typique à l'image d'un câble qui fraye
sous les mers pour faire transiter nos
like celui ci l'a pas d'impact en
revanche arrivé dans un data center là
c'est un impact d'avoir ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que le soleil ne se
couche jamais cher sur internet ne peut
pas éteindre internet vous pouvez pas
attendre plus de trois secondes pour une
page internet c'est insupportable donc
en fait il va falloir ce qu'on appelle
la disponibilité de service c'est-à-dire
que si jamais il ya un datacenter qui
tombe en panne il faut automatiquement
qui est un datacenter qui prennent le
relais dont vous avez des datacenters
qui tombe tout seul qui ne servent à
rien mais qui potentiellement pourrait
servir le jour le datacenter amiral
tomberait en panne et puis ces
datacenters il n'y a pas qu'une seule
entrée dès l'arrivée d'électricité vous
en avez 2 3 puis vous avez des
générateurs électriques qui se met
automatiquement en marche si jamais les
principales sources d'électricité tombe
en panne elle aussi à nous aussi et puis
il faut de l'eau alors il faut de l'eau
parce qu'il faut de l'eau pour tout
simplement refroidir enfin pour
permettre le refroidissement des
systèmes
de refroidissement la climatisation dans
les datacenters et donc en fait cette
espèce de multiplication du stockage de
la donner sachez juste que si vous avez
un compte gmail il est stocké six ou
sept fois dans six ou dix sept
différents endroits de la terre ceci
vous est temps qu'on vous allez vous
connecter en fait à un data center qui
est proche de hong kong si vous êtes en
amérique latine vous avez vous connecter
un centre de données qui est proche de
l'endroit où vous vous trouvez et donc
cette multiplication et bien de centres
de données de la du stockage de la donne
et redondés génère énormément d'impact
électrique est donc toujours plus d'eau
forcément pour être capable de les
refroidir et alors vous parlez de ce
data center qui se trouve dans le grand
nord mme c'est là où tout les toutes les
données européennes
de facebook mais aussi de ses filiales
whatsapp ou instagram sont stockées
c'est en suède alors qu'est-ce qu'il est
particulier ceux des tests d'abord c'est
l'histoire d'un mec parce que facebook
donc a besoin de ses propres de centres
de données décide d'en ouvrir de nouveau
tout d'un coup facebook se font
engueuler parce qu'on se rend compte que
tout ça ça tourne au charbon est en fait
l'enjeu est là pour facebook en 2013
c'est d'aller installer un datacenter
qui ne n'ai pas besoin de consommer
d'eau ou d'électricité pour refroidir
ses systèmes ses serveurs on a donc là
où on peut juste ouvrir la fenêtre et
laisser le froid rentrée pour parler
simplement et puis là où l'électricité
n'est pas produite à partir du charbon
mais provient des barrages
hydroélectriques or c'est une
électricité qui ne met pas ou peu de
carbone et donc du coup il ya un double
enjeu ici fin de réputation et
d'efficacité énergétique à facebook à
venir faire migrer tous nos like toutes
nos photos de vacances tous nos toute
notre activité s'est fait dans une toute
petite ville qui s'appelle loup les eaux
au fin fond de la suède à 100 km du
cercle arctique et de construire le data
center là et donc du coup je le vois
et mais quand on y pense on se dit mais
attendez si on mettait une bombe là
il y aurait plus de l'ail plus de photos
plus rien sur facebook alors on danse en
tout cas si c'est ça c'est la fin de
facebook donc ces six l'infrastructure
physique meurt il n'y a plus de vie dans
le monde virtuel oui voix en sarre le
lien pour facebook à mon avis pris
toutes les précautions pour éviter ce
genre de situation là ils ont un autre
datacenter qui à leur datacenter
historique qui se trouve à prineville
dans leur aide de l'état d'oregon aux
états unis qui semble-t-il or je suis
pas sûr de tout parce que c'est très
secret ce monde là mais stoke en double
tout les deux disques durs qui se
trouvent probablement également dansé
dans le sur le datacenter qui se trouve
donc enfin il ya plusieurs halles où les
eaux probablement inversement d'aller
voir des datacenter miroir partout
certainement je ne connais pas mais je
pense pas que facebook prenne le moindre
risque pour que nous ne puissions pas
laïque et autant que possible il faut se
dire qu'il ya plus de 3 millions de
datacenter dans le monde alors un
datacenter ça peut être tout petit comme
un frigidaire
voilà ça peut être le centre de données
dans lequel sont stockées les données de
votre entreprise se trouve dans un
placard à balais et puis tout est là et
puis après ça aussi ça grossit savoie 6
puis ça devient des datacenter aille
parce qu'elle comme on dit là c'est à
dire des cendres données qui sont
absolument gigantesque le plus grand du
monde fait la taille à la surface 210
terrains de foot ont pas forcément au
sol mais parce qu'il va y avoir d
étagement france handi terrain de
football c'est quand même colossal pour
stocker des données
andré center également ce qui a beaucoup
frappé un datacenter de grande taille
mais sans être non plus énorme ça peut
consommer jusqu'à 100000 l'électricité
de une ville de 100000 habitants pour
nos données n'ont pas oublié que c'est
pour ces usages là qui sont censément
immatériel oui comment ça on est rendu
compte pour les bitcoins récemment
d'ailleurs les bitcoins c'est une
consommation absolument effrénée à
chaque fois qu'on achète un bide comme
si consommation effrénée c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique du danemark juste le bitcoin
ya plein de crypto monnaie mais juste le
bitcoin c'est ça et c'est heureux 0 25 %
de la consommation électrique mondiale
et puis derrière cette ces chiffres là
se pose une question à quoi sert le
bitcoin à quoi servent les crypto
monnaie moi je connais plein d'amis qui
vous est un autre débat à quoi sert cet
internet qui polluent est ce qu'il est
une silhouette ce qu'il ait là quoi sert
elle
vous expliquez dans cette revivre à quel
point quand on prend un sale fille et
qu'on le poste en fait on fait
travailler des mines de charbon et donc
on envoie du co2 dans l'atmosphère
à quoi sert à cmfi c'est un débat parce
que moi je dirais un tick tock ça sert à
rien mais un adolescent me dire à
l'envers si on dirait que c'est
absolument indispensable pour sa vie
sociale et un bon internet d'être un
moins bon internet internet et son site
internet superflu à quoi sert internet
quand on sait ça qu on voulait faire
servir et on peut imaginer qu au regard
du père du pétrole qui ont été
extrêmement nombreuses on a même parlé
d'une malédiction du pétrole quand un
pays se révèle être un pays pétrolier il
lui arrive d'état dormi tout à coup on
peut imaginer aussi que les routes du
numérique celle que vous avez emprunté
pendant deux ans vont devenir le terrain
de guerre qu'on peut tout à fait
imaginer en fait quand on parle de
présence physique d'internet de réalité
matérielle internet ça veut dire
concrètement que les infrastructures
bien sont littéralement sur le sol sous
la mer soûles et sous la terre mais ce
sont des infrastructures qui existent
pour de vrai et puis ce sont des
infrastructures vitales critique en cas
de guerre qu'est ce qu'on va sûr qu'on
va balancer une bombe en premier ou un
missile ce sont ce type d'infrastructure
là donc à un moment quand on dit ça on
comprend que ces infrastructures aux
vocations être espionnés à être écoutés
à être peut-être sectionné littéralement
un câble sectionné une action
malveillante et donc à être protégé donc
en fait tout d'un coup on voit
apparaître une géopolitique des câbles
terrestres et sous-marins et
géopolitique où les états vont avoir
intérêt à espionner les autres états est
précisément ces infrastructures et à se
protéger et donc du coup toutes ces
routes du numérique et je pense
notamment la route de la soie numérique
chinoise puisque la route de la soie
chinoise s'est pas seulement les routes
les choix de chemin de fer et les porcs
mais c'est aussi les câbles optiques et
notamment ce câble qui s'appelle pis
comme la paix et qui arrive à marseille
en 2022 en passant par l'asie centrale
notamment ces câbles là et bien ont
vocation à être protégé est ce que
demain la chine arguera de la nécessaire
protection des infrastructures vitales
pour à et déployer ses armées après tout
la france déploie ses armées en afrique
notamment au tchad pour protéger ses
ressortissants français que fera la
chine vous durera t g où le rhénium que
fera la chine pour protéger ses propres
infrastructures et est-ce qu'il n'ya pas
ici s'inquiètent en tout cas un think
tank américain une justification à une
expansion de la présence physique
militaire de la chine pour protéger ses
infrastructures d'un monde censément
immatériel donc moi je pense que des
stars se feront la guerre demain pour
que nous sur la toile nous puissions
nous distraire mais de manière je vais
aller jouer à l'uranium ou au pétrole
vous avez écrit un livre précédent qui
s'est intitulé la guerre des métaux
rares c'était tout ces métaux qui nous
servent à
fabriquer de téléphones portables nos
ordinateurs nos drones nous avions
combats ces métaux rares là aussi ils
sont ils se trouvaient certains endroits
on les rafina d'autres et ça fait partie
des enjeux aujourd'hui aussi importants
voire peut-être plus important dans le
futur que pétrole c'est un nouveau
pétrole ces matières premières dites
rares parce qu'elles sont plus rares que
les métaux abondant je pense en
particulier
je confirme complètement votre propos
j'ai souscrit est d'ailleurs une
actualité intéressante l'afghanistan est
aux mains des talibans l'afghanistan
regorge de lithium
terrestre grande depuis un certain temps
et le lithium c'est nécessaire pour les
batteries de téléphones portables
étaient rares c'est le vibreur de votre
téléphone portable téléphone portable
quand il vibre c'est parce qu'il ya un
peu de terres rares de dans une traque
on appelle le néodyme les chinois sont
très intéressés par ces matières
premières la ils sont déjà intéressés
par le cuivre afghans est-ce qu'ils vont
venir dans le vide laissé par les
américains signé des contrats avec les
talibans richalet talibans pour que nous
puissions nous ensuite aller cliquer sur
le téléphone portable voilà c'est des
vrais questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui à mesure que nous étendons
notre impact numérique et donc physique
sous le monde et est de même
l'approvisionnement est important c'est
à dire que si les chinois ont le
monopole de certains certains métaux
rares c'est un problème c'est un
problème d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui la
chine détient en particulier 95% enfin
jusqu'à 95% de la production de
certaines terres rares or cette terreur
sont stratégiques pas seulement pour le
téléphone mais également pour les
technologies de défense les missiles
intelligents les f-35 l'équivalent de
notre rafale en france aux états unis
s'appelle le f 35 il faut 400 kg terres
rares qu'elles sont 17 kg de terreur
pour un f 35 si l'américain d'aller
servir en chine c'est une dépendance qui
est très problématique donc tout d'un
coup by denver
ouvrir des mines aux états unis
notamment de ses terres rares veulent et
raffinée sur son territoire pour ne pas
être dépendant de la chine sur ce volet
extrêmement stratégique si je me
souviens bien de la lecture de votre
votre livre précédent je crois que nous
raffinons des terres rares les français
et on les a abandonnés c'est trop
polluants ont la bonne elle avec l'ado
chinois dans les années 80 en disant
c'est tellement sale mais vichy doit
qu'ils en aiguille on était absolument
ravis de se débarrasser de ce fardeau
c'était dégueulasse pourtant c'était
nécessaire pour fabriquer notamment
aujourd'hui 90 % des voitures
électriques et on a été trop content
laisser le job pour aux chinois qui à
l'époque n'avait qu'un souci c'était de
s'enrichir peu importe le coût
environnemental que cela générerait et
et tout le monde y est allé de bon coeur
nous en délocalisant cette pollution les
chinois s'enrichissent ans et puis
aujourd'hui le fardeau est devenu un
atout puisque la chine ne peut réserver
ces métaux pour elle-même peut décider
de ne plus nous en vendre et puis elle
peut aussi dire je ne vois pas le métaux
mais je vous le métal mais je vous vends
le téléphone portable avec le métal
intérieur donc je remonte la chaîne de
valeur et du coup je m'enrichis et puis
vous vous perdez en fait de la de la
production industrielle voilà le sous
titre de la guerre des métaux rares
ça pourrait être aussi le sous titre ii
du livre qui vient de paraître l'enfer
du numérique c'était la face cachée de
la transition énergétique et numérique
on voit bien que c'est extrêmement
polluant et que la transition écologique
au fond est-ce que c'était une véritable
transition
j'imagine que dans derrière votre livre
il ya cette question là qui doit pas
déplaire à tous ceux qui n'aiment pas
beaucoup quand catherine berg et qui se
disent au fond tout ça pour rien
bon déjà c'est sûr que la voiture
électrique pose immense questions en
termes de pollution environnementale on
peut revenir évoqué les analyses de
cycle de vie et puis dans ce livre là en
fer numérique je m'interroge sur les
contradictions de la génération gretar
la génération greta nous dit plus
d'avions moins de viande attention aux
plastiques ce que au demeurant je trouve
tout à fait intéressant et moi je suis
plutôt admiratif du courage de greta
tony berg cette génération est une
génération qui se mobilisent grâce aux
outils numériques la génération climat
c'est une génération numérique et qui se
mobilisent grâce à ces outils là est par
ailleurs pour regarder un peu les jeunes
autour de moi j'en ai dans la famille de
15 à 25 ans ils sont accros à ces outils
là un jeune de 25 ans en france a déjà
eu cinq téléphones portables entre ses
mains il en est au sixième
ces jeunes aimé moi aussi venir nous
consommons fortement de ces outils
numériques avec un impact écologique
nous ne voyons pas et donc de façon
volontairement provocatrice je pose la
question est ce que la génération greta
est réellement la génération climat est
ce que d'un côté ces économies de viande
de billets d'avion et de plastique que
souhaite cette génération elle n'est pas
contrebalancer dans notre côté par tous
les impacts directs et indirects avec
les nouveaux modes de consommation que
permettent les technologies numériques
qui vont être forcément générés par
cette génération qui est accro à ces
outils là et est-ce que paradoxalement
la génération greta n'est pas celle qui
aggravera l'impact du numérique directs
indirects et peut-on lui faire confiance
pour la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
est ce que ça pourrait être plus
vertueux
où est-ce qu'on est condamné à cette
gabegie et de matières premières de
métaux rares
de d'électricité
dow alors ça pourrait être infiniment
plus vertueux et c'est pas un livre de
constats l'enfer numérique série de
solutions d'abord j'ai fait le tour du
monde pour raconter parce qu'elle est
rencontres avec des gens extraordinaires
qui ont qui font des tas de choses
intéressantes et puis il ya des tas de
solutions pour être plus vertueux des
solutions très concrètes d'abord la
moitié de la pollution numérique avec
taddei ce téléphone portable la moitié
donc si je garde mon téléphone deux fois
plus longtemps dans cette moitié là elle
est déjà divisé par deux je schématise
mais c'est pour vous dire à quel point
le simple fait on peut agir facilement
concrètement au quotidien juste avec ce
qu'on appelle nos interfaces numériques
c'est à dire les téléphones les
tablettes les ordinateurs
en faisant l'effort de garder plus
longtemps les faisant réparer et de la
sorte déjà en jouant un immense impact
on peut vraiment améliorer là l'effet
vertueux précisément du numérique s'agit
pas de se priver numérique mais on peut
faire beaucoup mieux en étant beaucoup
plus responsable rien que sur cet aspect
là est il chez en plus on pouvait poster
moins de like moins deux vidéos de chats
mais vous poser une question fait
d'actualité parce qu'en fait
on va me répondre mais attendez moi
poster les likes est ma raison de vivre
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
inséré dans la société ça consiste à
débattre de la question de savoir s'il
ya internet qui est utile ou l'internet
qui est superflu et sans que ça pousse
d'immenses question en fait et en fait
ça rejoint des débats qui sont déjà
engagés qui sont des débats sur la
question de savoir s'il faut pas réservé
de la bande internet à certains usages
qui sont plus importants que d'autres
s'y est de la bande passante ben est ce
que je dois pas la garder pour un
hôpital connectés plutôt que pour une
vidéo sur tik tok oui mais la question
va se poser pour cette émission par
exemple elle varie selon les émissions
est ce qu'il faut la stocker
éternellement watch dit oui vous venez
donc me diront c'est franchement pas
utile et c'est exactement ça sa queue à
la sortie des lycées on dira t'on
hôpital connectés j'en ai rien à carrer
ce que je veux c'est ma vidéo tik tok
mais beaucoup plus utile au quotidien
celle qui me permet de survivre au
quotidien et en fait se posera une
question c'est celle de la neutralité du
web le web c'est neutre c'est-à-dire que
tout un chacun peut aller sur le web
standards du web vous avez pas besoin de
décliner votre identité vous avez pas
besoin de dire pour quel usage et donc
vous avez toutes façons à bande passante
appartement où voulez vous voilà ce qu
en plus d'internet est de plus en plus
disponibles poser cette question c'est
remettre de l'interdît ont
potentiellement l'hiérarchie dont de
l'interdît dans l'outil qui est par
définition le plus libre possible est
celui qui nous offre le plus de liberté
et donc est ce que demain il va falloir
apprendre des mesures liberticides pour
précisément limiter notre consommation
de like ou de données je ne sais
laquelle c'est des questions qui vont
pas se poser demain mais n'oubliez pas
qu'en chine on vient de dire que les
adolescents devaient pas trop passer de
temps sur les jeux vidéo par jour ou par
semaine faut être un état totalitaire et
autocratique pour prendre ce type de
décision mais tout d'un coup on pose la
question d' interdit à propos d'une
technologie qui était censé pouvoir tout
nous permettre je n'ai pas encore très
très longtemps en france la télévision
s'arrêter à minuit on se considérait pas
comme un état totalitaire et avec une
chaîne même les secours venant disant un
peu en arrière ou vingt ans en arrière
on passe pas pour des jeux totalitaire
l'enfer numérique voyage au bouddha lay
que c'est le nouveau livre enquête de
guillaume pitron qui vient de paraître
aux éditions les liens qui libèrent ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après avec david alain cotte
[Musique]
et voici des vidéos un code qui est sur
son 31 il est venu dans son costume de
scène
bonjour merci merci
c'est le même depuis toujours c'est pas
le même depuis toujours mais depuis le
spectacle cm ce blouson bleu qui est un
peu chétif j'en ai plusieurs d'ailleurs
c'est mieux aucun sens
donc vous êtes humoristes vous jouez
votre nouveau spectacle ça va aller tous
les mercredis tous les vendredis
jusqu'au 17 200 décembre à la nouvelle
scène et l'image qui symbolise le mieux
notre époque à vos yeux c'est celle ci
qu'est ce que ça représente pas c'était
c'était macron qui a reçu les athlètes
les athlètes des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour leur faire la leçon
en fait voilà donc les jusqu'au bout il
fait la leçon il à dire il n'y a pas eu
assez de médailles on peut faire mieux
ayadi savoureux mets en 2024 il faut
qu'on fasse mieux et tout ce à quoi
teddy riner a répondu que toute façon
c'était trop tard pour 2024 pour ça
jamais prêt parce qu'il faut des années
de préparation et ben moi il fait
vraiment penser à de plus en plus à ce
pote qu'on a qu'on invite un
déménagement c'est qu'ils restent assis
sur la caisse et qui donne des ordres
aux autres en disant ah le canafe cette
place comme ça je le voudrais voilà
c'est ça pour moi ma poule l'inspecteur
des travaux finis mais ça a toujours été
un souci j'ai tous les chefs de d'état
ils veulent toujours que les athlètes
que nous voyons là maintenant c'étaient
eux qui s'adressait ils veulent toujours
qu'on rapporte plus de médailles oui
bien sûr on a fait les jeux olympiques
de grenoble 68 c'est parce qu'on n'avait
pas eu de médaille en 60 ans mais là
c'est vrai mais j'ai l'impression que
d'autres le faisait un peu plus
adroitement ou alors ou alors on avait
carrément rien à comme chirac et
je sais pas c'était plus sympathique où
le général de gaulle dont on fait les
jeux olympiques de grenoble il y va même
pas là voilà moi je préfère ça
finalement ça c'est une opinion assez
arrêté sur les jeux olympiques je trouve
que c'est totalement quelque chose d'un
autre siècle qu'il faut arrêter
d'ailleurs si on les a eus cette année
enfin pour 2024 c'est une personne
d'autre ne voulait donc c'est
parlant de votre spectacle à la nouvelle
scène la nouvelle scène sur une péniche
on va la voir en photo elle est juste
sous notre dame
est-ce que ça tant mieux quand on n'est
pas ce que j'aime de boue on est il faut
bien comprendre qu'on est sur le bras de
la seine le plus le plus étroit oui et
il se trouve que vous avez un verre posé
sur un codeur équilibre sur un tabouret
à côté de mots je me suis dit est ce que
le verre peut tomber non s'attendent pas
à ce point là il ya des fois un bateau
qui passe très vite notamment la police
le regard de sylviane je peux passer
très vite ou alors un bateau mouche qui
veut faire une petite pointe et des fois
on ressent un petit coup à léogâne tombe
au chili toute façon même s'il va pas
vite ouais il ya un petit courant alors
en 100% un petit coup c'est très bizarre
mais jamais au point de faire tomber
quelque chose mais c'est agréable ce
petit coup moi j'aime bien je me sens un
peu flottant pendant tout le spectacle
je voyais ça aide un peu être dans une
bonne attitude détendue finalement oui
et laisser les gens avec des basques qui
vous regarde alors
c'est spécial fait une blague dessus
d'ailleurs quand les gens en ont trop
ils ont au moins ces temps ci je sais
pas s'il commet ce sera maintenant à la
nouvelle scène mais ces derniers temps
dans les comédies club c'est quand même
un peu plus clairsemés donc c'est plus
agréable ou au mieux les gens ou parce
que je sais même pas s'ils rient bas à
part les yeux plissés mon jeu c'est pas
toujours enfin je les entends quand même
oui
le votre spectacle est influencé par la
pandémie puisqu'il s'intitule ça va
aller il se veut résolument optimiste
bien bienveillant et inclusif c'est
exactement le contraire de tous les
autres spectacles qui eux se veulent
absolument corrosif voilà c'est ça mais
je jouerai je crois que j'en ai un peu
marre au 22 de dire aux gens ce qu'ils
allaient voir mais j'ai préféré leur
dire ce qui n'allait pas voir pas du
tout un spectacle intimiste évidemment
mais voilà je va vers la fin et j'avais
décidé de sourire un petit peu sur cette
affiche c'est là et met alors en
revanche je vous aie il ya des petites
caractéristiques de vos précédents
spectacles que j'avais abandonné il ya
beaucoup moins name dropping
que autrefois des têtes de turc il reste
un petit peu quand on est un petit peu
c'est les politiques
ça compte pas céder ce sont des têtes de
turc de toute façon il ya un peu moins
d'un home jacking parce que j'essaie
d'avoir des sujets un peu plus long
peut-être
je parle pas mal l'environnement je
parle pas mal de
féminisme en fait je j'examine plutôt
les luttes des autres en fait je réagis
aux luttes entre féministes entre
entre entre entre personnes militantes
en fait et j'essaie de d'en tirer
quelque chose de drôle et de pas donneur
de leçons vous en prenez plus aux
marques comme dans animal elles vous ont
tapé sur les doigts alors j'ai prévenu
que ça peut leur coûter cher à vrai dire
ça a beaucoup plu j'en ai gardé un petit
peu quand même j'en ai gardé un petit
peu sous le pied notamment nike voilà
que c'est pareil tyco ces voix là où on
a plus l'impression que c'est une marque
c'est vrai c'est que c'est un culte donc
non je regarde un petit peu et pigeons
avec chaque chaque semaine j'actualise
un peu donc il ya toujours des choses
qui reviennent et notamment cette marque
de jus d'orange là qui a fait à une
bouteille avec des insultes dessus qui a
dû être retiré de monoprix donc ça va là
je vais en parler un petit peu et puis
je rappelle que les marques qui l'ont
fait vivre un certain temps oui vous
étiez elle était dans la vie si terme et
dans une autre vie mais je mords la main
qui m'a nourri donc c'est un david
azencot très différent de celui qu'on
connaît qui est sur la scène
actuellement de la nouvelle scène
propose quelques extraits
gbe sabu tabou dans le désordre en plus
moi je sors du coc vide voilà je sors du
comics et c'est nul
de la voir à la fin
ça n'intéresse plus personne
impression d'avoir chopé le sida en 2010
apprend t caché que si je te dise et
arman qui est accusé d'agression
sexuelle dire c'est quand même le
premier flic de france le type il est en
charge des violences policières pardon
de l'institution policière
ma langue a fourché par mon nom en plus
vraiment je suis alors c'est pas le
genre de la maison moi je suis pas dans
le police bashing en plus j'ai entendu
au gouvernement ils ont dit vous en
faites pas maintenant la police va être
poli courtoise
je sais pas les crs vont arriver ils
vont faire c'est à vous ses beaux yeux
là
moi je les ramasse du coup je voulais
rang voilà
moi je suis féministe moi j'ai féministe
parce que parce qu'on est obligés
c'est un petit peu quand même sens un
peu le vent du boulet nous les avons
jamais eu une manif manif féministe
vraiment hardcore justement de
confinement je me rappelle le slogan sur
la banderole ça disait un homme mort ne
viole pas
oui
oui je vais dire un homme mort ne
descend pas les poubelles non plus donc
voilà
faut faire un pas vers nous quand même
on est ensemble vous savez que tous les
présidents d'ailleurs la république en
france on leur offre un labrador si tous
les présidents ont labrador s'échapper
du mali c'est gentil c'est qu'on doit
symboliser les françaises
avec leurs travers
et ils ont tous un labrador et j'imagine
tous les présidents avoir un
comportement avec leur labrador un
comportement normal tu vois j'imagine
bien chirac en train de faire et léo
lepers et les enveloppes et or
j'imagine bien sarkozy est en train de
lancer un bâton à son labrador j'imagine
même hollande allant chercher la balle
que labrador lui a lancé tu vas y aura
là c'est compliqué c'est compliqué le
voile je vais être un tabou c'est
compliqué parce que j'entends le choix
tout ça mais et l'autre fois dans la rue
j'ai vu une petite fille de 5 6 ans et
je me suis dit quand même le choix
et après j'ai réfléchi réfléchit c'est
vrai que le voile en théorie c'est la
pudeur de la femme c'est la non
harmonisation du corps féminin et pain
ça marche la gamine j'avais pas du tout
envie de la baiser
soit une petite hésitation rigoler comme
on voudrait pas tant changé que ça non
en vrai nom c'est alerte c'était faux
les becs sur la pédophilie continue vous
fait rire oui alors d'autant plus que je
le dis dans mon spectacle je vais te
papa et je pense que c'est le moment
d'en faire encore plus et voilà il faut
pas s'arrêter de rire des sujets qui
peut-être vous touche plus sa force
parce que vous êtes plus sensibles en
tant que parent c'est toujours ce qu'on
m'a dit on m'a dit quand tu seras perds
tu verras tatata est bon pour l'instant
non ça va ça fait toujours de rien vous
êtes l'un des rares à remettre en
question la notion de deux d'emprise oui
normalement on y touche sur par 1100
personnes normales oui oui et non c'est
un sujet très délicat et très il faut il
faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit pas
ce que l'on veut pas blesser les gens
non plus mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
emprise c'est ce que je dis un spectacle
et un peu reprise par tout le monde en
fait c'est à dire plutôt que le dire
j'étais avec un con on va dire ben
j'étais sous l'emprise où j'étais avec
une conne marché dans les deux sens et
ce que j'ai d'ailleurs je dis moi aussi
j'étais avec des cônes qui mentaient
qu'il manipulait ouvrage était pas
souvent prise j'étais juste amoureux en
fait j'étais bête et je vous vois très
bien ce que c'est qu'une situation
d'emprise une vraie situation de reprise
mais j'ai l'impression que des fois ça
tourne un peu au joker quoi la wii au
mot valise en fait vous allez pêche
jusqu'à remettre en cause les sidération
non non non non non c'est
non mais la sidération ces jeux et a
quand même dire qu'un des sujets qui
sont très difficiles à aborder sur scène
pas parce qu'ils sont à bout mais parce
qu'ils sont dit si c'est difficile de
faire rire dessus quoi l'emprise il se
trouve que je reprends des mots que je
fais quand même dropping qu'anne
sinclair a dit à propos de décès
l'emprise non pas de quelqu'un qui ont
ensuite dit j'ai été violée l'ehpad il
était sous android c'est le cas de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas vu voilà qui est
dit il m'a trompée en débat et a trompé
ses baladins de trouver un nouveau mot
en fait c'est pas grave c'est grave
évidemment c'est grave mais pour toi
mais sinon voilà il a pas obliger à
faire des trucs ignoble je dis voilà g
data pas obligé avec laquelle tu lionel
jospin on est partout c'qui est
effectivement on peut ne pas se rendre
compte parfois on est payé et la nature
de la manipulation des relations
amoureuses s'assemble et puis alors il
ya les relous qui harcèlent les femmes
dans la rue comme marlène schiappa a mis
hors la loi oui malines chaque pas et
elle vous assure pas mal oui elle a un
petit peu droit à un traitement de
faveur
en fait je sais vraiment pas volontaire
en fait c'est juste que tous ces gens
alimente tellement la machine à bêtises
tout le temps quasiment toutes les
semaines par une nouvelle mesure idiote
nouvelles mesures annoncées parce
qu'elle ait jamais suivies d'effet que
ça voilà c'est obligé d'en parler et je
doive être le quartier sans relou certes
c'était le vrai terme qui voulait mettre
sur le des crèches où on en est arrivé à
un point on va d'ailleurs j'ai écouté
tout de suite sur scène parlant du du
quartier sont relou souhaitait pas mal
et ne lui a pas
si collier de marlène schiappa en fait
c'est faire une espèce de réserve
où les femmes seraient enfin tranquille
c'est
le jour se lève sur le quartier sans
relou mal à la jeune gazelles se rend au
point d'eau
tous ses sens sont aux aguets car elle
sait que les relous sur la roma bon
album aux albums aux alpes en moselle
elle entend déjà leurs cris les relous
chastan meute derrière un mâle alpha
reconnaissable à ses trois bandes adidas
avec sa robe tachetée même jusqu'au bout
des sabots malassé qu'elle va être
victime de la loi de la jungle
heureusement les gardiens du troupeau
sont là reconnaissables à leur fourrure
bleue et leur laine de pastis
bien vite les relous s'égaillent dans la
nature au bord du seul but
mais la journée n'est pas finie pour ma
là car les gardiens demandent eux aussi
souvent leur récompense bonjour
mademoiselle on se promène
l'argumentation des patrouilles de
policiers dans certains quartiers il
devrait amener de la baisse des remous
mais je dis c'est que mondiaux les
relous iront dans un autre quartier un
relou ses mobiles c'est pas de statut
donc ça c'est des annonces toute façon
c'est même pas suivies d'effet encore
une fois vous avez fait sciences po
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait l'ena ce
que je suis une feignasse je crois qu'il
faut quand même reconnaître que les
énarques sont des vrais travailleurs
dans leurs études et puis j'avais pas
vraiment envie de partir dans ce circuit
là je crois je passais rester un petit
peu de côté et faire des blagues et
commenter ce que faisaient les autres
pensaient que cette bascule des liens
problème avec l'autorité les
institutions en général j'ai aussi
peut-être un problème avec certaines
institutions mais j'ai des amis qui ont
suivi le cursus et qui maintenant des
postes dans la diplomatie par exemple et
je trouve ça assez facilement en fait
mais peut-être que j'aurais du mal moi
défendre des opinions des autres les
opinions du gouvernement les choix du
gouvernement peut-être un petit peu
difficile quand on a envie de ce tout
fabriqué au même si aujourd'hui c'est
assez frustrant du temps où ou les
voyages étaient très long on imagine
bien ce que ça pouvait avoir d'exaltant
d'être l'ambassadeur de france à moscou
mais aujourd'hui je suis le prochain
téléphone emmanuel macron par la ville a
dit mme lacouture bruit des fois je me
demande à quoi servirait d'intermédiaire
en fait voilà parler des avoués ou un
certain 11 heures d'écouté par
l'ambassadeur et dit n'importe quoi ou
alors ça sert parfois écouter ce que
disent mais voilà fait des antennes avec
un petit micro voilà sa vie à sa merci
david alain cotte d'être venu dans cette
émission ça va aller c'est votre nouveau
spectacle tous les vendredis est la
nouvelle scène
[Musique]
il le guet vous êtes une grande pianiste
comme ont dit un titre dont peu peuvent
se prévaloir d'être quoi ce pour une
centaine un peu près dans le monde à
pouvoir dire dont on dit que vous êtes
des grands pianistes
questions vraiment difficiles
qu'est ce qu'un grand pianiste ça y est
une célèbre réponse qui est de donner sa
taille donc un a310
après qu'est ce que ça veut dire je
pense que c'était à ce qu'on va payer
pour venir vers moi que tous les cas pas
de payer on va les écouter
y compris quand ils ont totalement seul
avec un petit ado vous sortez un nouvel
album consacré à franz liszt votre
compositeurs de prédilection on va en
parler dans un instant mais d'abord une
image pour illustrer notre époque
cette image là voici qu'est ce qu'elle
vous qu'est ce qu'elle représente pour
vous alors d'abord c'est une image
demain et c'est vrai que pour pour une
pianiste la main c'est très important
c'est aussi la sensualité et cette image
c'est aussi un peu aller à l'encontre de
la distanciation de la peur de l'autre
du masque c'est se prendre par la main
c'est se retrouver c'est ce que l'on vit
maintenant que se retrouvent est
possible que les concerts sont possibles
que se réunir redevient possible et je
pense que c'est vraiment très important
c'est aussi la transmission qui est un
sujet qui m'est qui m'est cher on peut
imaginer que ce sont deux générations
différentes
c'est se prendre par la main c'est se
laisser guider c'est vrai qu'on a
comparé toujours des biens des pianistes
jab et de leurs pieds b vous en servez
pourtant à mais absolument et c'est très
très importants apportant les pieds
absolument le pied créer l'équilibré
sonore la durée du son c'est eux qui
vont
participez à l'harmonie avec avec le jeu
des pédales on va vous écoutez tout de
suite après tes rêves d'amour qui figure
sur joies de la joie de l'âme c'est le
titre de votre nouvel album rêves
d'amour sans véritables tubes de la
musique classique
il était composé par liszt en 1850 il
avait 38 ans est une star énorme à
l'époque qu'un franz liszt il fait des
tournées dans toute l'europe on parle de
lisztomania ça durerait pendant 25 ans
et puis composent rêve d'amour extraits
[Musique]
oh
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
e
c'est un musicien de l'ain team liste
comme chopin qui sont son contemporain
d'ailleurs et puisqu'elle mélodiste en
plus à l'époque c'est mes rêves d'amour
c'est une mélodie est extraordinaire
mais il se contente pas de la répéter
comme on le fait aujourd'hui quand on
fait une chanson oui la développe et si
jamais il la répète elle est toujours
transformé allait varier en fait liste
vous disiez tout à l'heure que c'était
le compresseur de l'intimé alors
absolument et c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de votre livre c'est pas
toujours comme ça qu on le monte on a
plutôt tendance à le montrer comme le
grand virtuose qu'il était il était un
extraordinaire pianiste mais en fait sa
musique englobe tout elle est à la fois
tendre et les passionnés à les virtuoses
aller poétique elle et littéraire c'est
vraiment tout à fait fascinant de voir à
quel point cette musique est riche elle
est mal mais le piano à la en à
l'honneur c'est vraiment elle fait
sonner le piano comme un orchestre il
était ce personnage fascinante il ya eu
trois vies en une voix la liste est
vraiment un
geste inutile à ce point c'est votre
quatrième album consacré à liszt je
crois que votre premier album c'était
déjà un album consacré à liszt qu'est ce
qui vous a fait écouter je pense que
voilà c'est une musique d'abord
extrêmement généreuse c'est une musique
qui peut nourrir une vie il a écrit des
centaines d'oeuvres et puis à ce
personnage fascinant qu'on retrouve à
travers sa musique ce personnage qui a
été un immense éducateurs ils n'étaient
faisait tomber les coeurs comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure c'est un très
grand virtuose qu'ils aient détourné ils
étaient acclamés c'est une des premières
stars n'avaient pas gagné au violon et
liste au piano et on a du mal à imaginer
quand ils arrivent quelque part il était
acclamé par les foules dans la ville
donc ce qui est vraiment absolument
incroyable et puis il est tombé fou
amoureux d'une femme s'appelle marie
d'agoult avec laquelle voilà il a arrêté
tout ce qui est
maintenant il composerait d'amour ce qui
dit voilà c'est l'amour unique il crée
il fonde une famille avec elles ont
trois enfants
et puis bon il ya aussi des tourments
qui arrivent là dedans bien sûr mais
lisse termine sa vie à b lui qui en
commençant sa vie ne savait pas s'il
allait devenir prêtre ou non finalement
créé une arche dans sa vie et termine à
b et donc il ya cette profondeur dans sa
musique il ya cette spiritualité qui est
là présente mélanger à la séduction
mélanger à la passion mélanger à la
sensualité et ça donne une oeuvre tout à
fait fascinante vous êtes avait commencé
le piano vous aviez 4 en cinq ans je
crois qu est ce qu elle rapport aux
autres thoniers avec votre instrument et
4 ou 5 ans est très différent du rapport
que vous entretenir aujourd'hui non
alors certainement et en même temps je
pense que l'essentiel est là c'est que
c'est un confident c'est mon meilleur
ami d'une certaine façon ah oui tiens
jours ah oui c'est à lui que je peux
confier mes joies mes peines
à tel point que parfois c'est même si
une peine est grande c'est même
difficile de jouer parce que y'a 7,7 au
delà de l'intimité en fait si le piano
c'est si je suis ce qu'est ce que
pourtant il ya des morceaux d'une
tristesse infinie que vous pourriez
prendre un immense plaisir à jouer quand
vous êtes heu oui pour aller encore pire
oui oui vous l'avez intitulé jouets de
là mais vous auriez pu l'appeler de
tristesse dollar est possible parce que
dans ces morceaux de liste il ya l'un et
l'autre tout à fait alors ça vient d'une
citation de liste ce titre les joies de
l'âme qui est ce n'est pas par les
surfaces c'est par les profondeurs que
se révèlent les joies de l'âme donc
c'est tout injustement un jeu entre la
joie qui en fait se la fait bien plus
que joyeux ain c'est là c'est la joie
profonde et qui en qui englobe justement
tout ça à 7,7 sensualité et cette
recherche de spiritualité vous jouerez
demain car marie le guay au théâtre
olympia d'arcachon vous avez joué sur
les plus grandes scènes
du monde
la philharmonie de paris pleyel car des
gi au look ou d'élisabeth au laquelle et
laquelle votre préférence bien des
tribunes d'abord je ne sais pas je pense
que chaque eu est vraiment différent je
crois que chaque rencontre est
différente il ya le lieu mais ya le
public il ya ce qui se passe avec la
présence du public et ça je pense qu'on
l'a encore pu se mesurer avec c'est moi
ou on a été séparée c'est que la
présence du public les coûts du public
ce fil tendu entre le musicien et le
public est irremplaçable quel que soit
le lieu alors bien sûr les lieux chargés
d'histoire ou par le carnegie hall 1 c
on en arrive là on s'est tous passé on
sent la présence de toutes ces
personnalités extraordinaires qui sont
passés à la philharmonie un son une
acoustique tout à fait exceptionnel ça
peut être aussi merveilleux doué dans
une petite salle oms en public tout
proche je crois vraiment que chaque
chaque lieu à son identité ce qui est
intéressant c'est de choisir les oeuvres
qui vont correspondre aux lieux et de
faire de chaque instant une rencontre le
1er octobre vous c'est vous le 1er
octobre je serai au théâtre du chêne et
à la grande scène du chesnay pour un
récital consacré à liszt justement quand
vous savez que vous allez être dans la
grande salle de la chesnaie vous allez
faire votre programme en fonction de la
salle oui d'autant plus que c'est une
série qui m'est confié une série qui
porte le titre de la vie est plus belle
en musique et donc c'est une série que
que je programme un peu sur mesure en
fonction de cette rencontre particulière
avec le public c'est un concert lors
duquel je guide les poudres que je donne
des clés des coûte pour justement
proposé d comme on ferait une visite
guidée dans un musée une visite guidée
de l'ecoute des oeuvres qui sont joués
vous donnez votre premier concert à 15
ans je crois vous souvenez de ce que
vous avez vu c'était déjà du liszt à
l'arrivée du brahms il y avait du bac
ils échouent man et sanogo garde de ce
qu'au premier concert une très grande
responsabilité
en fait c'était le premier concert
où justement le public payé sa place
vous en parlais tout à l'heure au début
de cet entretien
voilà c'était le passage à quelque chose
de une récente a été différente jusqu'au
là je jouais bien mal mon jeu quand on
paye sa place que vous soyez de grands
pianistes exact on en revient là
j'essaye de l'être en tout cas
donc il y avait cette responsabilité là
et puis 7-7 confiance de l'organisateur
qui s'appelle pascal escande qui a été
ce premier programmateur et cette
reconnaissance de cette chance qui m'a
été donnée vous n'avez pas la nostalgie
du temps où les musiciens lors c'était
avant liszt et chopin qui eux
les foules venues les acclamer est payé
très cher pour les voir mais avant cela
les musiciens étaient les employés même
avec rome domestique quasiment des des
seigneurs et des des églises vous n'avez
pas la nostalgie c'est très très
confortable on était en avait ça paye à
la fin du mois alors c'est fait
forcément pour le confort bien que bien
sûr ça c'est ce soit une chose
importante mais je dirais plutôt que
c'est parce que sa place le sujet
différemment dire qu'il s'agit plus de
jouer pour gagner de l'argent
c'est plus un sujet en fait sa place
l'art autrement sur un autre plan et ça
je dois dire que
j'aimerais j'aurais mais j'aurais aimé
connaître ça inversement l'histoire nous
montre que mozart a été le premier média
indépendant il a été le premier à
vouloir sortir justement de ces systèmes
sans doute parce que cette mise en
danger lui permettait d'aller plus loin
ou deux
donner une force créatrice différentes
mouches il n'y avait pas de situation
idéale il a payé très cher il aurait
bien aimé avoir un emploi il se trouve
que personne ne voulait lui a redonné un
oui mais du coup il a créé cette
indépendance et
je pense quelque chose à retenir des
deux les deux aspects et sans doute
effectivement la question importante de
ce qu'est la reconnaissance de l'artiste
et ça sans doute ça ça manque parfois
aujourd'hui le confinement vous l'avez
tout commence difficilement
douloureusement d'avoir cette perception
que la musique l'art pouvait ne pas être
essentiel
et inversement je pense que le retour à
au possible montre combien cette
essentielle au contraire ça a été une
période d'ajustement de maturation de ce
programme dont on parle ces oeuvres de
l'iss qui ont
vécu dans l'intimité
et justement ce programme qui parle
aussi des consolations
parle juste aussi je pense de ce qu'on a
traversé de ce dont on a besoin
peut-être maintenant se retrouver se
consoler
il parlait d'amour joie de l'âme c'est
votre nouvel album qui vient juste de
sortir claire-marie le guay et demain
vous serez d'arcachon
merci d'être venus dans cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]